Iran was going through a period of
demanding nationalization of his old
resources that's a very important
episode with mosadir whom you might have
heard about his name Dr Muhammad musadir
who was the Prime Minister and the
national charismatic leader
from
1951 to 1953 prior to that he was a
famous parliamentarian but this period
was the Prime Minister of Iran anti
nationalized the Iranian oil industry
and the British didn't like it at all
and eventually resulted in a famous crew
which at least partly was supported by
the funding
and by the moral supports of the British
and the Americans particulated by the
Americas it was always
seen as one of the earliest and the most
successful CIA operations during the
Cold War to see I had something to do
with this of course that's one of the
earliest operations of the CIA wait a
minute what was yes of course what was
the same what was the CIA doing CIA this
is the time at the post for era in the
50s in the 50s 40s and the 50s
the British Empire which was
really the major superpower of the
region after the collapse of the desires
Empire
gradually took the second
seat
to the Americans to where the newcomers
and the great powers and the victors of
the second World War
and the Americans viewed Iran as an
important
uh as an important country since it has
the largest uh common borders with the
Soviet Union
and it's what I did the size was the
Persian God which at the time was the
greatest uh uh supplier of uh oil to the
outside world and therefore the
Americans uh had a particular interest
in Iraq and in the earlier stages their
interest was in the interest of the
Iranian government because they wanted
to get rid of both
the Soviet Union which made the return
in the post-war era and of course the
British that were gradually withdrawing
from you know but they they had a full
control over the anglo-iranian or
company they changed the name to angular
Iranian or company
when the name of the country officially
changed from Persia to Iran
in the west
the name of the company changed and they
got into a huge dispute with the was
other government that eventually led to
the coup of 1953 which eventually
created it very
uh very distressful memory
in the minds of many of the Iranian
nationalists that this was the betrayer
of the great Powers the British and
Americans yes CIA played a part because
see I feared contrary to the British
that they were afraid of their own oil
in Iran the CIA was afraid of the Soviet
penetration in in the South and
particularly because there was a very
powerful
a very powerful Communist Party in the
two-day party of Iran
so they
gradually shifted between the Truman
Administration and our Eisenhower
Administration these are early days of
the CIA and then they actually did
participate uh to send their agents
there's a long story to that and it
eventually resulted in a successful coup
that removed mosadir from Power what's
the United States interest here why are
they using CIA are they trying to make
sure
there's not too much centralization of
power in this region they were afraid of
the fact that the
that of the Soviet Union and during the
Cold War that was the cancer
they actually almost want to protect
Iran and its own Sovereign processes
from the influence of the Soviets yes
because they were afraid of the fact
if Iran or at least this is part of the
I'm simplifying a very complex picture
but the but but the Americans basically
were thinking that if Iran is going to
be lost
true Soviet influence
then eventually basically the all the
oil resources in the Persian Gulf are
going to be threatened
and therefore and this would basically
is the National Security of the United
States and all of the western allies
European allies
so in a sense this was the long arm of
the CIA to try to
to try to make sure that that's not
going to happen and then of course they
were persuaded by the British because
British were the old hands which were in
Iran since the beginning of the 19th
century they always had relations with
Iran and so forth so they gradually
replaced and and of course they don't
want to give them this kind of a satanic
view that American was a bad influence
because they had also some very good
influences in Iraq but this particular
episode
somehow
shared a dark light
on the American presence that was used
that abused time and again particularly
the revolution
1979 which was this great Satan idea
that Khomeini created basically was
based on the fact is
1953 you were responsible for the
downfall of a national government in
Iran which as a matter of fact he had no
respect with Khomeini had no respect for
the national secular National liberals
including Muhammad Musa but he was using
it as a as a rhetorical tool for his own
purposes but what happened is that after
1953
we see again the rise of authoritarian
Muhammad result's power
and then he is that's the Shah that's
the Shah that we know as sure this is
the son of researcher and uh technically
what what is Shah is it is an old term
impression
that comes from a pre-islamic portion of
ancient times in the context of
democracy should it be seen as like a
supreme leader King is the head of the
executive power according to the
Constitution of 1906. oh that's in the
Constitution they actually yeah as a
place in the Constitution but the actual
term sure okay interesting what they
show is a very old term yeah it's almost
like a monarchic term like uh like a
king yeah it is actually is the term
peculiar to Iran I've written about it
somewhere but because the term that the
Western World in the ancient times has
been Rex for royalty and the King
in the Eastern World in India is Raj is
the same origin the same route
Iran never shared that they had the idea
of it because the extended I don't want
to get into the too much of a etymology
but this is an interesting one yeah Rex
and Raj both means the one that opens
the road for
basically in four set of religion okay
um in uh enforcer of the right religion
because Rex and Raj both have the uh of
the astrological
origin of Rights
you see and right means the right
religion basically by the way there's so
much beautiful language here I'm just
looking at the the Persian constitution
in 1906 and it says it's the
constitution of the sublime state of
Persia kajar Iran I mean just just the
extra adjectives on top of this stuff is
beautiful I mean yeah because that was
actually the change that came about I
don't want to go in too much into it but
it was called as I pointed out before
the guarded domains of Iraq yes they
changed that to the sublime state of
Iran during the Constitutional
Revolution because they wanted to give a
greater sense of centrality of this
state yeah and Sublime was the term
refused but also what permeates all this
is a is a poetic I mean there is a
history of poetry of course based to the
culture it's just fascinating so I mean
it's I I of course I don't speak the
language but even in in Russian there's
also
a music
to the soul of the people that
represents itself that presents itself
in the form of poetry and literature in
the way that it doesn't in the in the
English-speaking world I don't know what
that is there's um there's a Romantics
like romantic romantic side that's right
yeah I agree with you in Iran of course
you know it is the time of the
Constitution Revolution it's a time of
great poetry
this kind of a patriotic
sentiments that comes through poetry
plays a very important part of course
these days poetry has kind of declined
and instead you see the visual image
that is at the center that's why Cinema
is so important because these days with
their Tick Tock yeah let me finish this
about this period of my Mother's Day
sure he built up because he received the
greater income
from the old revenue and to build up a
very strong state with a strong security
Force
a strong security apparatus which is the
savark there's a which is a acronym for
the security force in security
organization
and he of course unfortunately in the
1960s and 70s particularly 1970s
basically suppress the voices of or
possibility of any kind of a mass
participation in the political uh
process it became very much an
authoritarian regime with its own
technocrats
very much a modernist
vision of of of of
Iran's future and almost kind of
Messianic that he was hoping that Iran
in a decade would become the fifth most
powerful estate in the world and the
riches as he would have said the gates
of the great civilization very much in
the mind
had this image of ancient Iran of the
Ikea mini Empire and we want to go back
to that greatness of the archimedian
Empire somewhat rather naive and very
nationalistic and crude fashion and what
happened is that as a result there was
built up some kind of a resistance from
the intellectuals from the left
eventually resulting in a kind of a
protest movement as I said by 1977 1978.
then of course the question that comes
to mind and the probably it you have you
you would like to know about is the fact
that why it becomes religious why to
become Islamic if it's the popular
you know nationalist liberal tendency of
opening up the political uh uh space
and along greater participation going
back to the Constitution
of 1906 1907 why it's all of a sudden it
becomes where does he come from
the reason for that at least in a
concise fashion is the fact that on one
area
that
after the greatest suppression of all
the other voices remained
open was religion masks
the mullahs on the pulpit
and the message that gradually shifted
from the older traditional message of
the Sharia of Islam I mean all the rules
and regulations of how one has to live
into something very political
and not only political but also radical
political
so
in the whole period from the
Constitutional Revolution to the
revolution of 1979
basically the religious establishment
gradually was pushed to the opposition
they were not originally very
conservative supported us of State as
the Catholic church for instance was
supported of majority of the
authoritarian governments around the
world
but the politicization
was the result of isolation
because they were left out of the system
and while in isolation they did they did
not they were not successful
in
trying to reform themselves to try to
become to try to find answers to many of
the questions from Modern Times what
happens to women what happens to civil
rights what happens to a civil society
how the modern law and individual
freedoms have to be defined in Islamic
terms how to separate uh religion and
state or how to separate the religion
and state these issues were never
addressed
what happened is that there was this
bypass through political
uh Islam and
revolutionary Islam as it gradually they
learned you know that this is the bypass
bypass to power basically to become
again a voice in the society and
eventually a prominent voice and
eventually monolithic voice and the
society that's the process that led into
the revolution of 1979 basically this
period
greater attention was paid to religion
even among the secular middle classes
who were alienated
for a very long time because of this
extensive modernization of the parallel
period they had they didn't have a sense
of that old models with their turbans
but they became they had a kind of aura
in this period yes they are those who
remain not corrupted
they are the people who basically went
against the suppression of the palavi
regime and Khomeini became a leader a
symbol of that nobody ever thought in
the earlier stages
among this very excited multitudes that
came to the streets of the Iranian
cities in 1979 or 1978 actually
thought that this this old one line with
70s
that all of a sudden has appeared from
the najaf
through Paris to Tehran is going to take
over and create a autocracy a religious
orthocracy